zone ふーんこの人俺におりバレてお茶かけてますねサーフ
私肇社長 youtube で動画を出し始めて結構年数が経ってるんですけども
メインチャンネルだけでダンス的な動画の数230012本あるわけなんですよ
[音楽]
すまんだいとうかたっくさんあるあんすいません自身貼って俺をないんで全裸だが
面白いせよっていたらいいんですけども遊んの自信がなくて
なんだつまらない動画の方が多いと思ってるんですけどそんなのはやっぱ自分の中で
まあまあ面白い見たいなぁとが動画もあるかもしれないんですけどーつまんない堂野聡
が多いんですけどもやっぱり2312本あると
この俺が今まで出してきた同様中でどれが一番つまんないのかなって思いまして今回
ですね
肇社長の動画のつまらない動画ランキングベスト5を紹介したいと思います
ちなみにあの俺はまだセラないですしめっちゃ気になってるし
傷つく準備ができていますというわけでいろんな人に聴いてもすべての人が2310
日本の動画も見ているわけでもないと思うんで弾み薩摩藩からはずねぇどのファンの皆
様に安全一つの玉のつまらない動画を教えてってアンケートを取った結果を基につまら
ない動画ランキングを作らせていただきました
さすがのファンの皆さんだったらどうがたくさん見てるだろうということでかなり的確
につまらない
動画が性質されていると思ってるんですね信じていますというわけでこの動画で僕の
動画のつまらなされはっきり分かると言う2カ国の企画ですね
ではさっそく見て行きました
ぶっ
実はもう早速見ていきましょううわぁ山傷つくだけないよってもいきます
始め山荘の面白くない動画ランキング第5位
[音楽]
髪はちょっと甘詰に落ち込みました小生同じで5本あります
第5位2012年9月1日公開送金のしょうもない動画
2012年11月21熱気球に踊るタンタン2010間に2月中4日公開ミーティング
では専門家と対等に話せるんじゃに後編2019年12月8日公開風呂わたっている服
が袋は任せていると
霧201009/10/14すべきこんな命を賭けたマニュアルパニックは嫌だ
このご本がランクインでございます
ございます
ん
[音楽]
入って月1本ずつ見ていきましょう方でごめんですねこれやバーってカー
顔壊れて本当にで背中マニーを飲んでいるだけの動画ですよね
再生開始だが123番回すごいなってと動画てが1分56秒ね昔の耽ってるんですよ
8コメントがですねーって面白くないわけではないんですけども今と比べて言っ
beauty がスピード感がないのでそう感じでしまうんだと思います
一番初めの動画はある意味上に敷きてイキってるあたりをもそれですけどプロ動画は名
の通りでしたというコメントを頂いておりますありがとうございます
[音楽]
鳥肌立つ書を釣るで not 後は8君を取る参加ですねこれで俺を生んで動画[ __ ]が
あって迷うが意味わかんなかっ
こちらです
メインチャンネルで5万回再生です
まずでサンタがを取るだけの動画ですねとコメント何を伝えたいのかわからなかった
1分もない短さと意味不明さで逆に面白い気もしますが今この動画が県としても確実に
つまらないと思って選びました
どうぞ
動きが面白かったのにそれで当時の僕からするとサンタの腰の動きが面白くていう
ついて撮っちゃったっていう2012年だから8年前の動画ですこれ
[音楽]
やばい甘い坊
今だしたらバッチ罰方がいるだろうなこんなの骨がガランペンでございますおめでとう
ございます
ここらへんまずつまんないなと思う設備でウキペディアで見てれば専門家と対等に
話せる者に後編
はい骨がですねあの
ちょっとマニアックすぎてあとは俺も思いましたいろんな専門がいるんですよ不思議な
専門家難しい事は沢山つが専門家とかいやするたびにミッキピラーを見ながら会話し
ようっていう動画の後編なんですけど
はいこういう形で専門家の方が話せるですけども du 内容が難しくて飛ばしてみ
ましたでしょうね企画力はすごいと思うけど開運のレベルが高すぎて一般人には何言っ
てるかよくわからなかった
視聴者さん置き去りにしたつまらないパターンですねこういう難しい ip route
が出てくるんですよ
こういう文字がたくさん出てくるっていう隅で置き去りにしていった動画の経過粒
つまらなくなったみたいな感じです
おめでとうございます頭痛いで8フローを明かしているはずがそれは私ているとって
見えこれをボロいと思ったんだけどなぁ
ダメだったかなぁ腕の通りですねフロア化してくる塗ってフロアを沸かしてくる動画な
んですよ
つまらなかった理由がつまらなすぎて逆に好きですが戯れに無理がある
ありがとうございますじゃあ風呂敷まーす
cme
ジャブをもういいかじゃないかな
ん
ねぇ
[音楽]
皆をてがー
[拍手]
いいいいいい
こんな感じ黒を出していきます行ったらスロは私てるよっていうトッキーですねー
[音楽]
はいさせ次が小皿ですねすん意気込んな命をかけた真面目にパニックは嫌だ
受け子最近ですねはい小皿ですねあのマニャーニパニックをたくさん使った寸劇の動画
なんですけどねかちょっとその本気で万全にパニックやってる人たちにイメージで作っ
たんですけどとコメントが心の声は顔芸は大げさだけど最後まで面白い
部分がほとんどなかった
いつも弾み社長のようなはっちゃけた感じじゃないので
なるほどだろう
付けた方がいいね恋貴重な意見頂きました
これいいわけだしてくださいなんでこれ作ったかって言うと俺何も考えずには2倍
たくさん買っちゃったんですよ
入らないなと思ったんですけどなんかどうしようと思ったけど6でひねり出して作っ
たっていうのがこの道なんですよな
分ずつ救いがたわけじゃないんですよめっちゃなんかず政府とかノートにまとめたんだ
けどなぁ
頑張ったからって面白いってわけじゃないんですが面倒がっこんな感じでマニュアル
パネルずっとやってる動画です確かにつまらんはい以上が第5位でした鯉で国株っての
すごい住んで強いやつゾイド第4位で何良い
2つありますまず1つ目
2020年6月2日公開この動画を絶対に買いみてください
おめでとうございます絶対に回見てっていう動画ですねそしてもう一つ
君となればいろんなユーチューバーの無意識ドイツに入ってみた
頑張ったんだけどまぁ公約まで準備スタローンにありがとうございますね見ていき
ましょうかこの道絶対にが
みてくださいってやつこれあの2回見てって言ったらみんな2回見るじゃないですかた
ので再生回数が倍になるということで平均の再生改正が伸びるんじゃないかというただ
の検証動画なんですけども
コメントが2回見てって言われてももう一度見たいと思う内容ではなくあまり見る気に
なりませんでした
格好でもみましたスッキ何周を見てて気づいたら寝てたから
するんですよね
内容はないんですよね本当に回見ていって言ってるだけなんですねこの動画のタイトル
通りに解除歳でしたけどこの道の結果発表がない
なるほど
これですね結果発表せずともですね再生回数が結果発表なんですね
[音楽]
これはちょっとあのつまんなーいん純正にたまに何も考えて面白さ考えず純正にどうぞ
だしちゃうのはちょっと僕の rx ですねはい続いて a 結構最近つけました機密
苗場いろんなユーチューバーの無意識領域に入ってみた
いやーこれねちょっと頑張ったと思うんですけどねコメント機密の刃の流行りにのって
みた考えりあまり面白くなっ
あったです
あのねぇ
ヘリに乗りたかった捉えて焼き別アイパワー煙霧の真似してるんですけども m の
マネーが見てないです
ちょっとにでなり内にを舌口決めたいが溢れちゃった感じですね本当に
機密に会えばを見てないからそのネタがわからなくても強くなかった
確か狐神じゃない人からそれとちょっとわかりにくいところだと思うんですけど
ぜひ気密ネイル映画見たかってみてください個人的だったけど面白かったんですけど
ちょっと何か欲しいのうん頷いたないなぁ
続いて第3位ですってタイプ
ます
マジで第3位2015年7月11日僕が異世界最大系の君一人で食う
これが3位なぁえええいっちょくさい閉店のにこれけっこう有名というかの5秒
チャンネルで1番再生されている道なんですけども再生穴位置おっぱい超えている動画
ですが
ただ本当にグミを食べてるだけの動画なんで再生数のその
対1に対してはつまらないです間違いなく源さんを知りたての頃に1番人気の動画をが
知りたくてみたのですがあれってなりました
そうだよねただでかいグミを食べてるだけでなんで海外に人気かが分かりません
なんかきっと r ですよね組が特徴的すぎて見てる不思議だから再生されたみたいな
ところはあると思います
だこれ面白くて爆散されてるわけじゃないつまらないから逆に面白いだから再生回数が
多い私も嫌いじゃないよ
ありがとうございますそれでキャー逆にを沿いてそれ
閉祭式カットデー
はいが続いて第2位見ていきましょう第2
一番演習頑張ったねー無限分身でございます
移動がこちらです
あの一定のリズムで僕が無限に変身していけだけど動画なんですよ弊社好きなんで
ちょっと分していないなぁと思って振っしたら面白いんじゃないかなぁと思って
めちゃくちゃ編集時間かけてやったんですけども
全然再生されなかったし面白くなかっっていう動画で一番良くないパターン
いやーこりゃ
でもなんかよくよく振り返ってみるとあの助けが分線してるだけだなんでよ
だったらなんかなるとの分身見てた方がいいなっていう面白くないというよりは主張前
もし眺望もなんだこれってなった
たよねー力この動画の編集に9時間も費やしたなと思いました
この動画は人類にはまだ早かったみたいですそうです
こいつってですよね第一これでは良いよ
流行る第1コアな僕のファンの皆様がこれが一番つまらないって言ったらでもまあ前約
このチャンネルで僕が今まで出してきた所中でつまらない動画がこちらになります
これがはじめ社長の妻出会いです第二話
うーんこれ第一2019年2月18日公開
大量な鏡が反射で対応を一点に集中させず国の豪華で焼肉をする予定
一番つまらないでさめでとうございます
どんな動画だっけ
などそもそも言い方スタートなのねー
はい鍵がたくさん準備したんですよそっか我々動画もやり始め雲日が暮れてるんだよ
なぁ
そこはよくないなーっていう太陽の日で使うんだと日中もと明るいときはやるべきです
ね
[音楽]
このめっちゃ早口ぐされている汗ぴたんでしょうね多分
うわぁ凄い
にもうちょっとから f 8
みんな覚えておくなよなから
たいと完成を繰り返す
トライ&エラーです
なるほどですね
これ二つをそういうことなんだろうね失敗で終わらずまたリベンジして欲しかった本人
は手応えは新しいが主張さがわからせると見応えのない動画
全てが中途半端だと気がする本当に出来そうと思ってたからいう形で成功しなかったの
が残念
仰る通りでございますこれは達花に言われてみたら
すげー中途半端ですねほんとに夕方にやんなきゃ良かったけどなんか色々焦ってって
忙しくても夕方にしかできなくてやってたんですよね
歯医者で埋まっていかなくてもその大倉にせずに動画にするようにしているんですけど
ちゃんと
年かそれをケアするために一応
動画のタイトルにかっこよてって言ったんですね
これ面白くないというか中途半端に終わらせてしまったっていうところですね
の方はよく見てますねこれは確かにつまらちゃんとやれって俺もみんなも思った
動画だったんだと思います
[音楽]
はいというわけでえとファンクラブの皆様心を痛めながらもつまらないとかを選んで
いただき本当にありがとうございました
なるほどなくり綺麗でないのがやっぱりよくないですねちょっと長年いう中だって言っ
てたんですけど改めて勉強になりましたはいという感じではなちゃんのつまらないと
わからんきゅうこちらになっております
概要欄にありますのでぜひそちらから集まんないぞ
が見てみてくださいぜひ高評価をチャンネル登録よろしくお願い致します
じゃん
ちょっと一派だ pl
あった